hey Garrett go go real pleasure Kenny do
you how are things
great good man yeah let's go out I want
to finally get some time on the books
I'm glad you been here for just over
three enough months awesome have my
90-day review two weeks ago how'd it go
right good what do you do I'm an ACC on
Lisa and David spot I'm filmin ACC on X
and done master how'd you get here I got
here long story I'm trying to catch on
gated I heard about you through Charley
means build a podcast and I've been
friends with Tyler since my farraday's
no [ __ ] you're grew up in Montclair [ __ ]
real play lacrosse together I love it
just one grade above me and saw that you
guys moved into hooking yards and I've
been coming here for another clown
upstairs for my old company okay I did
PR a small shop there and so I saw that
he posted a video of you touring his
office I was like oh my god the most
amazing office not being a few times and
so I hit a time I was like oh you worked
in vaynermedia know nothing about it I
just heard your name a few times
understood I looked into it I thought it
was amazing just the number of people
that worked here the amount of services
that you guys offered and how quickly
you guys have grown and I've always
wanted to go somewhere where I could see
myself in terms of demographic age and
skill set yeah and so I talked the time
from there it was just like all of us it
would and how's it been going
it's been great enjoy that games great I
love you in the ACC I lovely spot every
individual person on my team
so on either from strength we just
combined I work together well it's like
it's really good like not it's not a bad
it's awesome Anna makes me so happy
is a mile job I never get to Sunday
scary anymore like sure yeah I don't
makes me happy man where do you live
Jericho I moved from Jersey to Brooklyn
a year ago a little better very good how
are you thinking about your career like
went now that you've got a little bit of
lay of the land like do you want to mean
Lisa one thing like how do you think
about things so I know so I have account
experience miles out in the net here and
I've been thinking a lot I know I want
to be on the account rep for a while
just to get more experience in myself in
terms of this business running [ __ ] yeah
hmm um budget aspirations of
were on the town team I'm sorry I've
always had kind of a knack to working
with talent whether that was going to
music or entertainment so I think you
know if I'm hearing you right if you're
thinking in the mindset of you know
twenty four thirty six months on the
account side by the time if that plays
out and you get those skills which I
recommend because you'll get them more
there than you would the beta town
things gonna be a monster by then and
then there's just a million I mean I'm
sure the more you've been doing homework
on me and things that nature like I
don't know like their sports wasn't
supposed to be a thing you know Vayner
music's not a thing but the world thinks
it is like Buddha and it could be like
the entrepreneurial vibe is deep here so
good man and also uh I just want to show
you something sure how long this rain
here I came from my wag dog market
orientation and I was like I have ten
minutes to spare so I was watching the
last 10 minutes of billion I'm a TV show
on Showtime yep and one of the
characters the main character one of the
main characters who's trying to purchase
a horse my dad and if you happen to want
to purchase the guy okay
Angelica's on the phone with another
business partner and he says that in
America we the world to unite them with
sports franchises I've heard I've been
tweeted a little bit this morning about
it and I didn't know the thing for her
that I never heard that either
and I was like things happen for a
reason I was like I knew I had my
meeting with you today is line and I
don't know maybe go like this and I was
like this is like perfect I can't
believe you said I literally saw this
morning or last night on from some
tweets I never thought about that
it's interesting yeah I think I saw that
I was like my brain is blue you know big
guy in for sure not a coincidence
perfect timing anything I can answer for
you it was more personal questions
actually like sheriff you see reassure
because watching some of the videos last
night and specifically about like
telling people what they should do and
that like what they hope to do is kind
of be her true self
yeah like knowing what you know now if
you can like go back to your 25 we have
about 25 how would you best conquer this
I know it's the number one yeah the
number one thing you should do in this
company a little bit slightly turned on
what you just asked but the absolute
truth is you should get to know every
single person this company with every
ounce of my soul I'm telling you right
now every one of your lunches if you've
got the time and you're not on something
should be in the cafeteria and should
literally roll up and be like yo hey
it's everything people people of the
game the skills are commoditize my man
the skills of like taking good notes
being organized being on time being
smart they're stunningly commoditized
it's the relationships how'd you get
here you play lacrosse with somebody
relationships right you shake somebody's
hand you become friends with them it
sudden do you understand what
vaynermedia is going to be the in media
is going to be the company that spits
out the digital ninjas of the future
world somebody in this room right now is
literally the CEO of Nike right now
somebody in this office is the CEO of
Nike yeah 17 years from now would been
really good if you said what's up that
is the game now everybody's different
extrovert introvert the vanilla right
but that's it there's nothing even
remotely close know everything about
your team ask them how you can help them
bring value to other people I do it now
at this level
yeah like 25 meter like when you're here
that's that's what people remember yeah
give a [ __ ] Roger and then M everything
Pat said this morning also using a
visionary good things and I was like
that's what keep that so keep the engine
running and like it's something so small
but in that you said in all your videos
putting more positive content out there
it was just personal how are you doing
you're doing this well great job
I've just seen that in this environment
it seems to just reinforce so much more
enough work because it's a dictatorship
man this place is a dictatorship like
you're just not gonna be able to win
here with negativity
you know ya now- me should not be
confused with critical and pack xual
feedback like if Sally sucks she needs
to hear it in one way or the other and
there's only so much you can sugarcoat
you stink at your job but you're
absolutely right
like I don't know where you came from
but I know that no matter where people
come from negativity is allowed because
the player that's deploying the
negativity is bringing value in a
different way I don't play that [ __ ] I'm
the first one that would trade my
superstar player if he's bringing cancer
to my locker room first I'll send his
ass out for a third-round pick I don't
give a [ __ ] because he's not going to
win and everybody's like Lisa Jarrell
like these people know that's why and
it's cool right it's like fun oh you
don't dread Sunday you know you're not
walking into any room here and getting
yelled out for no [ __ ] reason and I
promise you it will happen and it does
happen those people get fired I can't
stop humans from doing [ __ ] I can just
react to what they do and then it
becomes something everybody knows right
and that becomes the culture
cool man really got me met portrayed
right dad no can't wait
[Music]